when you take on an engagement as a
lawyer the worst thing that you think
that can happen
is you'll lose the case you don't think
you're gonna get disbarred as a result
and you certainly don't think that
you're going to jail
especially when you're suing a private
company
but some people have accused chevron the
oil company of
doing just that putting lawyer stephen
donsinger
in jail for his lawsuit against them but
is that what really happened and is that
what happened in this particular case
well once upon a time lawyer stephen
donsinger famously won a case against
chevron for polluting the amazonian
rainforest in the ecuador he won
billions of dollars but donzinger has
been disbarred is under house arrest and
the plaintiffs in that case have never
been paid and now the eyes of the legal
world are on new york city where
donziger's contempt of court trial has
captured the attention of celebrities
legal commentators and social media so
what is the
stephen donsinger case all about
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer under house arrest because
that's where stephen donziger has been
while he awaits the outcome of a
contempt of court trial that stems from
a case
he started way back in 1993. so today
we're going to analyze the chevron
versus steve donsinger ordeal
how did we get here who bribed whom and
who was the real threat to the rule of
law
former attorney steve donzinger or
chevron oil but to understand what's
happening right now
in new york we have to understand what
some people call the amazon chernobyl
the doncica saga involves two different
legal disputes first there was the case
where indigenous people from ecuador
sued chevron for destroying parts of the
amazon rainforest
steve donzier was their lawyer and
although the plaintiffs won
they have been unable to collect the 9.5
billion dollars for
legal issues that we'll talk about in a
second the second dispute is chevron's
civil case against donsinger himself
where the company has accused him of
fraud and bribery in violation of
american racketeering laws
donzinger lost this lawsuit and then
failed to comply with multiple court
orders
that led to contempt of court charges
and this is why donsinger is currently
on trial
but the story of this goes way back to
the 1960s when texaco teamed up with a
military junta that had seized power in
ecuador to
drill for oil in the amazon these tribes
were hunter-gatherers who didn't even
have a word for oil
but it's alleged that texaco's
activities produced 16 billion gallons
of toxic runoff
a lot of which wound up in unregulated
shallow pits but most of the toxic
sludge was simply dumped into rivers
to facilitate the drilling texco created
a company town called lago adria
which became a typical oil boom town
with all the components needed for
drilling infrastructure
concrete walls holding tanks massive
drills and miles
of pipelines but in 1992 texaco ended
its ecuador operation
leaving behind this infrastructure plus
hundreds of open oil pits thousands of
waste pits near drinking
and fishing water and untold amounts of
contaminated wastewater how bad was the
situation in ecuador
well even now more than 50 years after
texco started drilling
the people who live there can't get
clean water from the river so they
collect rainwater or walk six miles to
fill plastic water jugs
from a water truck provided by a spanish
oil company this is why the situation
for local people has been called the
amazon chernobyl
and it's also why in 1993 donzer and a
small team of lawyers filed a lawsuit on
behalf of the people of lago agria
they filed the case in new york where
texco was headquartered the company
whose assets were eventually acquired by
chevron
sought to remove the litigation to
ecuador meaning take the litigation from
the united states and
put it in ecuador strategically the
company assumed that they would have a
better shot at winning the case in
ecuador
where they still had political clout
this complicated jurisdictional battle
took
10 years to resolve chevron won and the
case was removed to ecuador
and chevron has always maintained that
ecuadorian contamination is the
responsibility of texaco
even though chevron inherited the
company's assets around the world and
runs texaco as a subsidiary and it also
puts a fair amount of blame on petro
ecuador the state-run petrochemical
company
not surprisingly though even after the
case was removed to ecuador the case
still took years to complete as the
parties to the suit and independent
groups completed over
60 000 lab tests on soil and water
the results quote overwhelmingly showed
contamination traceable to texaco
but the testing process was contentious
and both sides crossed ethical lines
so we'll start with chevron's dirty
dealing it's alleged that chevron
concocted a scheme where it sent soil
and water samples to a friendly lab for
favorable results
we know about this because diego borja a
chevron contractor who admitted that
chevron worked with his uncle and wife
to create four
front companies which posed as
independent labs
there are recordings of borja discussing
his ability to produce enough evidence
to swing the case
to the plaintiffs if need be he said
that chevron understood exactly what he
was implying
and that the company promised that he
would be taken care of
crime does pay borja laughed in one of
these calls
chevron eventually helped borja and his
family move to the u.s chevron paid
borja's legal fees
helping him to become a naturalized
american citizen the company also paid
his rent and gave his family a monthly
stipend
chevron paid borja over 2 million
dollars and those are just the payments
the plaintiffs were able to
trace this raises a question is it legal
to pay a non-expert witness for
testimony and the answer to that
is actually no fact witnesses generally
may be reimbursed for expenses incurred
in time lost in connection with
litigation but they can't be paid to
testify or not testify for the substance
of their testimony
chevron has declined to comment on
borja's allegations beyond stating that
they are protecting him from retaliation
an american judge denied further
discovery into the nature of the borja
chevron arrangement
but let's talk about the allegations
against donzinger himself
chevron has accused donzinger of dirty
dealing and in
a diary entry later obtained by a u.s
court donzinger admits that he had
a secret contact with the
court-appointed expert who was supposed
to be independent
donsinger described the situation as a
quote bargain with the devil
we can't win with the devil because they
chevron can always pay
more there's also evidence that
donsinger paid for the expert report and
may have written parts of it although
american lawyers
don't write expert reports in our legal
system lawyers do pay experts and exert
some influence over how the reports are
written
in the ecuadorian case the expert report
was written by a colorado company called
stratus
many experts say that the expert reports
scientific analysis was sound however
according to a report in rolling stone
chevron played hardball with stratus
pressuring insurance companies to cancel
its coverage with stratus
and leaning on its clients to cancel
contracts with the company
eventually stratus faced bankruptcy and
in a move that may or may not be related
its executives signed an agreement with
chevron explicitly disavowing its work
in ecuador as
fraudulent but to get back to the
verdict in the ecuadorian case
this issue with a stratus report may be
nothing more than a distraction from the
bigger picture
the ecuadorian court granted chevron's
motion to exclude the expert report from
consideration
in the end the ecuadorian court found
for the plaintiffs without relying on
the controversial report
and this nine-year legal saga generated
a 220
000 page record with over 100 expert
reports
testimony from dozens of witnesses
scientific data from 54 court supervised
inspections
and independent health evaluations and
in the end the court found that texaco
chevron had dumped billions of gallons
of water containing toxic chemicals in
waterways and on the jungle floor
used online waste pits that contaminated
the soil and groundwater
never cleaned up the frequent oil spills
maintain a policy of destroying
documents related to oil spills
and burning natural gas that
contaminated the air on february 14
2011 a judge entered a judgment against
chevron for over 19 billion dollars
which was later reduced to 9.5 billion
dollars
it was upheld by ecuadorian appeals
courts in 2012 and
2013. and this was pretty much the last
good thing that happened for the lago
augury of plaintiffs
so that takes us to the american case of
chevron vs donzinger
after chevron lost the ecuadorian case
it dropped a bombshell that would change
the trajectory of this whole entire saga
they allege that donzinger bribed an
ecuadorian judge
after the trial former ecuadorian judge
alberto guerra came forward with the
story that the legal team for the
ecuadorians
offered him a bribe to ghostwrite the
judgment against chevron
garros said that he asked chevron for a
bribe first and they turned him down so
he then went to donsinger
he says he sought bribes on behalf of
judge nicholas zambrano
the judge who actually issued the final
judgment in the case and according to
guerra
he and zambrano shared 500 thousand
dollars in kickbacks paid by donzinger
this is the testimony that chevron used
to sue donsinger under us
anti-racketeering laws which takes us to
a rare case of rico
the organized crime control act of 1970
also known as the racketeer influenced
and corrupt organizations act or rico
was originally enacted to help the
government stop organized crime
rico generally has two different flavors
civil and criminal
the government can prosecute a person
who operates or requires an
enterprise through a pattern of
racketeering activity
rico's criminal penalties include
imprisonment up to 20 years and even
life depending on the activity
and when congress passed rico their
expectation was that the vast majority
of rehab claims would be brought by
federal prosecutors however the law also
had a civil component that allows
private persons and entities to file
rico lawsuits rico's civil remedies
provision section 1964 c states quote
any person injured in his business or
property by reason of violation of
section 1962 of his chapter
may sue therefore in any appropriate u.s
district court and shot recovered
threefold the damages he sustains and
the cost of the suit
including reasonable attorneys fees
chevron as a private party and
person used a section to argue that the
ecuadorian verdict was obtained
fraudulently
and while the ecuadorian verdict was
upheld on appeal in ecuador
chevron doesn't need an ecuadorian court
all it needed to do was cast doubt on
the original legal proceedings
which would of course help them to avoid
paying a judgment in the united states
so let's talk about gara's testimony
here in 2011 chevron sued donsinger and
the plaintiffs alleging fraud and using
gara's testimony to prove its case
during the litigation garrett admitted
that when he was a judge he accepted
bribes and fixed
cases he also admitted that chevron
relocated him and his family to the u.s
and compensated him in much the same way
that it paid borja
however chevron says guerra legitimately
feared for his life and facilitated a
move to the united states to protect him
erwin chimorensky basically the guy that
everyone learns constitutional law from
in law school and also the dean of the
university of california irvine
school of law signed a declaration
criticizing the guerra evidence
if a party or its council were permitted
to pay a testifying witness for physical
evidence
beyond the reasonable value of that
evidence and to pay the witness's salary
in exchange for an agreement to testify
there would be little left to the rule
against compensating fact witnesses
that is precisely what has occurred here
notwithstanding u.s district judge lewin
kaplan found clear and convincing
evidence that donzinger and the
plaintiffs committed fraud bribery and
extortion to obtain
judgment over chevron guerra on many
occasions has acted deceitfully and
broken the law
but that does not necessarily mean that
it should be disregarded wholesale
judge kaplan also issued an injunction
barring the ecuadorian plaintiffs from
enforcing the judgment in american
courts
now chevron leveraged the kaplan
decision in the gary evans
internationally
convincing an arbitration tribunal in
the hague that the ecuadorian judgment
violated chevron's rights
interestingly at the arbitration in
front of the hague guerra recanted his
testimony again and claimed that he lied
about the whole kickback scheme
he claims he approached chevron with an
offer to manufacture testimony and to
increase his bargaining position he told
chevron plaintiffs offered him
a bribe and gareth testified that
chevron promised to pay him for making
up a story during his testimony garrett
admitted that he has no evidence of the
alleged bribes and forensic experts from
both parties agree that the draft
judgment was never found on either steve
donsinger's or guerra's computer but
similar to the american courts the haig
tribunal ruled that no court should
enforce the judgment because parts of it
were
corruptly ghostwritten in return for the
promise of a bribe
now after judge kaplan's ruling donziger
appealed to the u.s court of appeals for
the second circuit which is
the court of appeals is one step below
the supreme court donsinger argued that
judge kaplan's expansive reading of the
rico statute was not supported by case
law
the second circuit disagreed finding
that section 1964 was meant to allow
private citizens to be
prosecutors or attorneys general in this
private right of action quote
section 1964 subsection a gives federal
court's jurisdiction to hear rico claims
and
sets out general remedies including
injunctive relief subsection b makes it
clear
that the court on the application of the
attorney general has authority to grant
temporary injunctive relief even before
its final adjudication
and subsection c provides a private
right of action for any person
injured in his business or property by
reasons in violation of
section 1962. the second circuit held
that there is no legal principle that
stops the us court from granting a
company relief
from a foreign verdict and judge
kaplan's order certainly aided chevron's
attempts to avoid judgment and not only
did this injunction
bar in a u.s court from enforcing the
judgment it also set up a constructive
trust that would hold any proceeds that
plaintiffs obtained anywhere else in the
world now some have criticized this
strategy and the second circuit's
decision
as uh giving private actors like
corporations another way to go after
people who criticize their actions in
the context of free speech
this is known as generally a slap suit a
slap is an acronym for a strategic
lawsuit against public participation
and it's interesting because in this
particular case what chevron argued
successfully was that getting a lawsuit
or at least extorting
allegedly extorting a lawsuit in a
foreign jurisdiction
was a violation of a ricoh statute even
if a verdict is obtained in bad faith
it's extremely unusual to claim that
a lawsuit or the legal system in general
is
an arm of a ricoh enterprise but that
more or less takes us to the contempt
trial which is why stephen donzinger is
under house arrest to this day based on
the allegations of impropriety against
donzinger or i guess at this point the
findings of impropriety against
donsinger
chevron sued donsinger personally and
the court ordered dozinger to pay
chevron money that he had earned by
selling shares in the ecuadorian
judgment
eventually kaplan ordered donzinger to
pay chevron 813 thousand dollars
this is the order that has led to
donzinger's current trial chevron filed
motions with the court alleging that
donzinger
was hiding assets in order to avoid
paying up and the court ordered
donzinger to produce his cell phone
computer and other documents so that the
court could review evidence about his
assets
donzinger refused to comply with the
court's discovery orders he argued that
the materials would reveal decades of
communications he had had with his
clients which
arguably would be protected by
attorney-client privilege and while that
might be true
even if this information would reveal
some protected communications
courts deal with this kind of sensitive
information all the time
judges often review the material in
camera which means only the court is
looking at these documents and
they often allow redactions and they can
issue orders preventing the other side
from seeing protected information
but by refusing to comply with the
court's orders donzinger found himself
in contempt of court
and here's where things went sideways
again the judge judge kaplan appointed a
special prosecutor rita galvin
a former doj attorney now in private
practice to handle the contempt case
galvin's role was to prosecute on behalf
of the court the manhattan ausa twice
told the judge that
it was over tax and didn't have any
lawyers to spare in this contempt trial
kaplan went ahead with the prosecution
using galvin and something else this
unusual the maximum penalty for
misdemeanor contempt of federal court in
the situation is about six months in
prison
however the judge ordered donsinger to
be held under home confinement
because he's allegedly a flight risk due
to his interest in ecuador donzinger
has been under house arrest for more
than 600 days
more than four times the length of time
that he could be confined in prison if
he was convicted of the offense
donsinger's supporters which include
nobel laureates and international law
organizations
said that this is unprecedented for a
federal misdemeanor case
they and don zinger also argue that
given the punitive nature of this
prosecution he's entitled to a trial by
jury
the court has disagreed so donzinger's
fate will be decided by a judge
thus donziger appears to be in a
catch-22 situation he's been
confined for more than the time that he
could be sent to jail and is on the hook
for 800 thousand dollars
meanwhile the facts that have been
established in the american federal
court say that he bribed a judge
and the supreme court has denied
donsinger's petition for certiorari so
this means that the rico case is over so
the criminal contempt case is an
offshoot of
chevron's civil action against donziger
in that case judge kaplan ruled that
donzinger obtained the 8.6
billion judgment in ecuador against
chevron through fraudulent and corrupt
means
judge kaplan's judgment enjoined
donzinger from enforcing the ecuadorian
judgment in the united states or
attempting to profit from it
donzinger appealed his case to the
supreme court which
did not grant certiorari which means the
supreme court did not take up the case
and that meant that chevron won the case
and could move on to enforce the
judgment of the court and when a
plaintiff wins a judgment the next steps
usually include determining what assets
the defendant has to satisfy the
monetary judgment against that backdrop
judge kaplan ordered donzinger to
transfer to chevron
all property that he had or might later
obtain that could be traced
to the ecuadorian judgment and in 2018
chevron initiated post-judgment
discovery to identify assets available
to enforce its judgment against
donzinger so discovery can come at the
beginning of a case before the case is
over
and it can also come after the case when
you know you have to figure out
how you're going to get the money from
the person that you just won the money
against and the court also ordered
discovery to assess donsiger's
compliance with the judgment's
injunctive provisions
donzinger resisted this discovery
refusing to provide the requested
information and refusing to transfer
property
he sent a letter to judge kaplan stating
that he would prefer to be found in
contempt of court and then challenge the
contempt findings
in court proceedings the judge said
donsinger should turn over his
electronic devices to a forensic expert
so they could be imaged and examined for
responsive documents
donsinger refused to do this and so he
was found in contempt of court
and in the latest proceedings judge
prescott clearly expects donsinger to
attack her impartiality
as he's done in the past and as he's
done with judge kaplan and in late july
judge prescott finally issued her ruling
she found donsinger guilty of six counts
of contempt of court the 245-page ruling
is bound to be controversial judge
prescott agreed with donziger that
he may be the only lawyer ever
prosecuted by a private special counsel
in the southern district of new york
the judge said that the uniqueness of
the circumstances didn't render the
prosecution inappropriate or untoward
judge preschool's ruling said that
donsinger refused to comply with the
court orders and that was an attack
on the rule of law at stake here is the
fundamental principle that a party to
illegal action
must abide by court orders or risk
criminal sanctions no matter how
fervently he believes in the
righteousness of his cause
or how much he detests his adversary the
judge did not consider the wider context
of the chevron saga except to point out
that
she believed donzinger was sincere in
his beliefs that he's being persecuted
and so are his clients
as the judge pointed out quote this case
however is wholly unconcerned with the
debate regarding any responsibility
chevron might bear for that pollution
the only question before this court was
the very specific question of whether
donzinger had committed criminal
contempt in violation of 18 usc 401 to
secure a criminal conviction
for contempt of a court order
prosecutors have to prove three elements
one that the order was issued two that
the defendant's disobedience or
disregard of that order and
three the defendant's knowledge or
willfulness in disobeying that order the
judge ruled that the prosecution had
proved beyond a reasonable doubt that
donsinger received notice of the court
orders that he ignored the court orders
and that he did so willfully donsinger
on the other hand argued that his acts
were
ethically grounded in principled
objections that lawyers are permitted to
make
when they object to an abuse of power he
cited the case of in-ray mcconnell which
reversed
a contempt conviction of a lawyer who
insisted on pursuing a
forbidden line of questioning at trial
however judge prescott said that
mcconnell didn't apply here since
the contempt charges in that case were
under a different section of 401
which prohibits in-court acts that quote
obstruct the administration of justice
rather than the third section of section
401 which is the statute that donsinger
was charged
under section 401 3 prohibits
disobedience of lawful court orders
the judge also took issue with
donziger's assumption that the mcconnell
case allows lawyers to defy court orders
so long as their decisions were quote
ethically grounded
criminal contempt jurisprudence has no
safe harbor for conscientious objectors
indeed the law is clear that a party may
not challenge a court's order by
violating it instead
he must move to vacate or modify the
order or seek relief from the court of
appeals since this was not a trial about
chevron's responsibility for pollution
all judge prescott could do was
consider the facts of the contempt
charges here she found the quote a
lawyer of all people
should know that in the face of a
perceived injustice one may not
take the law into his own hands by
repeatedly and willfully defying judge
kaplan's orders
that is precisely what mr donzinger did
it's time to pay
the piper end quote the charges here
carry a maximum penalty of six months in
prison and donzinger has already served
over 700
days on house arrest so does that mean
that he'll be sentenced to time served
that's
definitely a possibility he'll be
sentenced shortly but we already know
that don zinger will appeal this ruling
he tweeted a statement to writing judge
prescott as a member of the
chevron-funded federalist society and
called his conviction a dark day for the
quote rule of law for democracy and our
planet
though of course donsinger's chances of
winning this appeal are incredibly slim
though we probably haven't heard the
last of steve donziger so if you're like
steve donsinger and you're
locked away in your home you'll love
today's sponsor hellofresh i mean why
would you even want to leave your home
if you can get hello fresh delivered i
have to say i was initially pretty
skeptical about hellofresh i'm a pretty
good cook so i didn't think that i
needed the help but
i actually loved it even for an
experienced cook hellofresh delivers new
ingredients and recipes that i would
never try on my own
everything i've gotten from hellofresh
was insanely delicious easy to cook and
really healthy and
most recently i made yogurt marinated
chicken with garlic sauce
pork tenderloin with cherry sauce and
meatloaf all a mom and every single one
of those was
fantastic and not something i would have
made on my own so if you feel like
you've been cooking the same thing every
day in quarantine
hellofresh is a great solution and of
course everything was delivered straight
to my door so i didn't have to do any
shopping the produce actually gets to
you faster than a grocery store so it
arrives at peak freshness and flavor and
it's also super easy to save time
hellofresh cuts out meal planning and
prep so
the recipes only take 20 to 30 minutes
to cook literally less time to cook
than it would normally take to do
shopping and it's also incredibly
sustainable
since the ingredients are pre-portioned
there's less prep and less wasted food
the packaging is almost entirely made
from recyclable or already recycled
content and hellofresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25
lower than that of meals made from
store-bought groceries
so if you would like to try hello fresh
and i recommend that you at least try it
you can go to hellofresh.com and use the
code legaleagle14 to get 14
free meals yes you can actually get 14
free meals plus
free shipping or you can just click on
the link below so again
for 14 free meals go to hellofresh.com
and use the code legale14
or just click on the link below plus
clicking on that link
really helps out this channel and while
you're at it click on this playlist over
here with all my other real law reviews
with explanations of today's legal news
so click on this link
or i'll see you in court